So let's take a look at the code, that
adds a task to the default task queue. So it's
createConference in Conference API, and then this is the code
that we already looked at to get the profile. Get
the conference key, get an ID for the conference
key. And here is the code to get the default
queue. And you're going to need, of course, when you did
this you would've needed to import queue and queue factory.
So, to get the default queue we just call
queuefactory.getdefaultqueue. I updated my code to use a transaction,
so here's the code for starting the transaction, ofy.transact,
and then we run it, we run the transaction. Then
we get the profile entity from the data store,
we create a new conference subject. We save the conference
in the profile, entities in the data store, this
is all code from before. This is a new code
to add the task. You see here that
the first argument is ofy, don't get transaction. This
is how you get the current transaction when
you're using Objectify. And then we add, we call
queue.add. And then the rest of the arguments to add are
TaskOptions.Builder. Basically, building up the task options with URL,
tasks, send confirmation email. Good job. I fixed the URL there, and then the
parameter you want to send the email and
we want to send the information about the conference.
Then we return the conference from the transaction.
And we finally, return the conference from the function.